[Music]
and you know we love a good
throwback check out blake at the acms in
the early 2000s
[Music]
how's my does my mullet look good man i
can't tell you crap about my outfit
in honor of that curly mullet mr shelton
kicks off et's look at when we
first met some of your favorite country
stars
[Applause]
you never forget your first tour and
keith urban will always be the one that
gave that to me so i'll be indebted to
him forever
everyone asks me um do you really love
country music and i didn't move to
nashville for the cheap rant
you know i've been playing it all my
life
luke grew up working on the family
peanut farm he
got his country music start writing
songs and he had zero shame about being
star struck
it's also fun when you get to come here
and be uh be here with big stars and
i mean you know i'm seeing heidi klum
and usher yeah our e.t
vault is filled with priceless vintage
moments with our favorite country
artists
hey y'all this is thomas any time you
put nelly and florida georgia line
together there's going to be some pretty
girls in a cool car and
a good time i'm better than you
i'm just like living in every moment
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm carrie underwood i am 21 and i'm
from chicago oklahoma i'm a t-shirt and
jeans kind of girl so i'm ready for
somebody to get a hold of me
and tell me what to wear and what to do
so carrie got her start as a contestant
on american idol
the college student had flown on a plane
for the first time
to get to hollywood three months later
carrie underwood
has any of this sunk in yet no not at
all
it's just been a complete whirlwind it's
just been crazy
it's hard to believe that just a few
years ago kane was working at
fedex and posting his songs on social
media
now he's 27 married and has a 17 month
old daughter kingsley
it's crazy i started in the bathroom i
grew up with nothing
and i'm just you know glad that i can
support myself now
[Music]
you can guest star on any disney channel
show past or present what would it be oh
my gosh hannah montana
all day every day that was my show just
say
what kelsey was just 14 when she went to
her first audition at a record label
at the time an exec told her quote
there's already a taylor swift
that slot is taken and speaking of tay
before
new male artist of the year winner jimmy
allen was famous he landed a role in her
commercial
it feels like a perfect night to dress
up
like hipsters but the 34 year old's road
to stardom wasn't easy
at one point he was homeless and lived
in his car and in 2011
jimmy made it to hollywood week on
american idol that someday it would lead
me back to you
but got cut before the top 24.
[Music]
i got into country music because my
daddy all he listened to is country
music i wouldn't be here without my
[Music]
father
[Music]
you